In your first round
of competition today,
you'll be using these.
These are .50 caliber flintlock
single-shot black powder
Trapper pistols will
use to forge signature
blades in your signature style.
COREY: [sighs]
Flintlock pistols?
What are we going to
do with these things?
It doesn't look like
there's any steel in them.
WIL WILLIS: You
will have 10 minutes
to work on your designs.
You will have three hours
to forge your blades.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your 10-minute design
window starts now.
COREY: Uh, I'm designing
a modified chef knife,
just because it's a fairly
easy shape for me to knock out.
WIL WILLIS: Your design
window is now closed.
Your three-hour forge
time starts now.
Oh, the poor, poor gun!
Bye!
I cut my hand on a barnacle
the day before I came here.
And this gauze makes
holding a hammer
in my right hand extremely
difficult, unfortunately.
So I feed it over
the power hammer
to do the initial forge weld.
That power hammer no joke!
MAN 1: He's got one
forge weld folded over.
He squished it flat.
And I don't think that
forge world is holding.
He's obviously fighting it.
COREY: The power hammer is
just way too aggressive.
I realize it's drawn
out way too much.
And I have a bunch
of delaminations.
[bleep] I have to just
continuously start
folding this fillet and
trying to consolidate
the steel into a solid block.
Otherwise, I'm screwed.
This could be [bleep].
Right now, the forge
welds are coming apart.
That's a major problem.
It's just sucky.
MAN 1: Corey will try to
press everything together.
And it looked to me
like he pressed parts
and it opened up other parts.
[groans] My arm's getting
tired and time's running out.
But as long as I can
get the welds to stick,
I know I can get a blade
shaped out quickly.
You just have 60 tiny little
minutes to finish your work!
His 4140 is not going
to get as hard as he
thinks he might be able to get.
MAN 1: But here's the thing.
It might not be as
hard as the file.
It's hard enough
to hold an edge.
I've decided this is as
hard as I can get this blade.
And I'm just going to
move on to the grinder
and start cleaning it up.
10, nine, eight, seven, six,
five, four, three, two, one.
Bladesmiths, shut down your
machines, drop your tools.
This round is over.
[whistling]
The overall shape of my
knife is acceptable to me.
The hardness, that's whatever.
Let the judges
take a look at it.
Now it's time for the
judges to take a closer
look at all of your work.
Tony, you're up first.
Your work out there
was textbook work,
from the use and
control of big blue
all the way to normalizing
and preparing your blade.
Masterful.
WIL WILLIS: All right, Corey.
You're up.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
MAN 2: Well, Corey, I like
the design of your knife.
It is a little bit snug here.
But sometimes, a
snug fit on the blade
makes it one with my whole hand.
It's just, how are you
going to transition
that if you move to the second
round to make it comfortable?
That's important.
You had me sweating
there in the beginning.
The first couple forge
welds didn't seem
to stick very well for you.
But you didn't give up.
And eventually, you
got the welds to stick.
I can see some evidence of the
welds maybe not being 100%.
But overall, well done.
- Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: Gage, you're up.
MAN 1: Good choice
on design for both
the apple slice and the chop.
There's a decided
warp, especially
on the backside of the blade.
You added that low carbon
steel to the back here.
That's a really good idea.
I'm just a little bit worried,
because I can see, right here
and right here, where
that weld starts
and starts to come together.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
completed their deliberation,
and they've made
their final decision.
It's time for one of
you to leave the forge.
Gage, your blade did
not make the cut.
Gage, your personal
integrity is not in question.
The structural integrity
of your blade is.
The junction where your
tang meets the blade
has crack and delam on it.
For that reason,
we're letting you go.